so basically I wanted to be a superhero
so I came up with a superhero from like
comic books like spider-man Superman
burn the boy first one was a song some
they from the Bible the whole song I was
just in a dark place and this was a song
that kind of felt like I wrote it at the
time so this is basically after my third
American for when I got these this one
this is like the rock star tattoo so
this P where says is this is rock if you
turn it like this and then I can tell it
like this it says stop you know so both
ways like this is rock star and then
like this is what's going on
[Music]
this says on my fingers as God's love I
feel like that's like the fuel of the oh
[Music]
yeah so this is like a wall like a brick
wall
and then it's got family graffiti on it
and then it's got like my family so some
of my family members names on it
scattered on around the wall this is
like a bleeding heart that still shines
so this kind of shows that mind even we
thought something might be shining but
it still needs you so this is Fela Kuti
fell on the property here as well it's
like my hero you know it's like the best
musician I ever knew and then under it
it says will you do so that's like they
nicknamed Fela and my granddad used to
call each other then I have the public
name it's like you know that in flames
that Pablo Escobar then mr. basically
that any people get of anywhere any
viruses Richie Furst my first album
first album Madiba scored like leave an
impact for eternity
but this one right here so this is our
national coat of arms this is River
Niger where the three rivers meet you
know then it says or more that jot that
means childhood Niger and then my best
friend
Dumbo recipes yah mahn so this is the
logo of people that follow me and there
was the cat symbol down to like it says
confit similar to his pious it's like
best of my current yeah this is Scarface
to eat still be good in from coming in I
can't let me tell you why I go ahead
only people that knew me in 2010 know
why don't jump into it just make sure
you you'll never be great make sure it's
something that you want to stay with you
from that like me only thing that got
it's a part of me
[Music]